ufos
as in us and explanation uf owes
us an explanation ufo uh yeah
an explanation is it i see what they did
right there
and you know who did that that's tom
zenner did that senator marco rubio
senator marco rubio told 60 minutes the
ufo is real and
the pentagon needs to investigate this
is the vt post story
sunday night florida senator marco rubio
went on 60 minutes and said there have
been enough credible sightings lately to
warn
some explanations and a full-fledged
investigation by congress rubio is the
head of the senate
intelligence committee so not only is he
privy to classified info what's going on
he is also in a position to help do
something to try to figure out
what these space vessels are going are
doing here the the point rubio made on
60 minutes
was tases flying objects
are a serious risk to national security
rubio demanded that the pentagon prepare
a report on what they know about the
ufos and report
should be available within a month
anyways did you guys see the video the
other day like a bunch of videos coming
out and pilots saying look i don't want
to talk about it i'm not somebody who
wants to go on television
but i tell you we've some weird we've
seen some weird things out there
where are you at with ufo's time you and
i have never had this conversation
before you got blasted up to space and
the aliens uh did the probe to you what
were your first thoughts
no no
[Laughter]
speaking of ufos i got to get a chance
to caroline this t is out of this world
really thank you there you go
i appreciate that respect that's very
nice ufos and out of this world very
good
so you can see what i did there all
right tell us about the probe go ahead
she did
the um no no no this is crazy it's like
reminds me of a sound
we're joking south park episode where
cartman ended up with a satellite disc
coming out of his butt remember that
i think something bad happened up there
to me um
all right tom here's here's what i think
there are too many videos out there that
are
um really credible uh the navy guys in
san diego and you've got the pilots
you've got the courting of the pilots
talking
and there was something going on down
there they talked about the tic tac
there was a tic tac shape
and it just disappeared went under water
yeah or something yeah and they
they saw actually saw a surface
disturbance you know so i i
you know i don't know do you believe in
ufos or no
that's true everybody wants to know this
does the biz doc believe in ufos forces
you're going to do a case study on your
force i don't think i believe in like
these elaborate
civilizations are living under the crest
of the earth no um
they're living in underwater but i
believe that there's something out there
that's moving moving pretty quickly and
there's some sort of phenomena and is it
defense phenomena and one part of the
defense you know isn't talking to the
other part
of the defense department about what
they're doing i don't know i think it's
um
i think it's a little creepy and you
know i can't explain
what i've seen and you've got so many
videos that it's not guys at home using
you know um final cut pro to make
something really kind of weird and
interesting
you know i mean they're showing it on
today on history channel on fox
on cnn on msnbc that this this
this thing goes up boom goes on the
water boom boom boom just moving really
quick
so so yeah someday they interviewed a
guy who was with the cia
he says we're not saying it is a uf
we're not saying it is rap
yeah we're not we're not against ufos
all we're saying is
we it may even be something used by our
enemies it could be russia could be
china
they don't know what it is all i'm
asking you tom you specifically you
this is on the record your kids are
watching right now yes brooke and bailey
are in school they're ditching
us to watch on the podcast here right
now that would happen that would happen
so
do you believe somewhere out there
there's ufos
i believe there are ufos but i'm not i
don't believe in some other civilization
someplace
you don't so you don't believe there's a
there's a there's an exactly duplicate
of earth
somewhere else out there in the space
well if there is i want to go find the
me that's out there and ask him if he's
in trouble with his wife too
so wow how about you
no i'm not no no on civilizations but
yes that there's phenomenas and these
things are flying
here's there's something real here's
what i trust in okay here's what i trust
in
here's what i trust in okay i trust in
math
and what i mean by math is the fact that
if math
tells us how much stuff is out there
that we haven't yet
done research on math is probably
leaning towards the fact that
there's probably civilization out there
there's probably
aliens out there math i'm a math guy
math is leaning towards
there's got to be something out there
what that is i have no idea
but there's definitely got to be
something out there if you think about
math
so you know how underwater you ever seen
a movie megalodon i don't know if you
ever seen the movie yeah the ridiculous
shark so what's more real
you believe more a megalodon exists or
ufos exist megalodons or ufos
if you're listening to this today though
today not not years ago
today do we have a megalodon today yes
or do we have ufos today no i don't
think so i don't think there's a loch
ness monster i don't think there's a
megalodon
you don't believe there's a megalodon no
not down there you believe that more
than an
alien yes do you believe there's a
megalodon
yes if you believe there's america sam
doesn't kai is there a megalodon
well in norway there's some sort of
creatures like that i don't know
specifically i'm talking megalodon like
a gigantic
bigger than one of these whale sharks
that's could eat a whale shark if it
wanted to it's
massive 60 feet 100 feet i think that's
more likely than aliens coming at the
depths of the ocean
i wouldn't underestimate it so you think
there's more what are you going with
you think there's more you're a math guy
so what's the math on this well i it's a
lot easier to go a few miles under water
than it is to go millions of miles in
space which means
if we have a few thousand miles to go
underwater whatever couple
you know how deep is the deepest part of
the ocean
the marianas trench is the deepest part
of it how deep is that i thought it was
like the inverse of everest
kai looked this up i thought it was like
35 000 feet the exact inverse of everest
so
by the way it's pitch black down there
sure it is the fish even got like kai
help me light bulbs coming off their
head the deepest
marianas trench
deeper than the abyss how deep is it
2500 kilometers in length
69. there it is minus 36. yeah i thought
it was pretty damn deep
yeah and how big is 11 000 meters deep
yeah
36 000 feet what what a tom what is that
in my in miles
well mile is 5280 so it's almost it's
closing in on seven miles
seven miles deep okay so here's the
thing just think about it okay now go
and see how deep is this space like how
far can the space go
you know what things are that's the
point so so if there's space how far is
the atmosphere or the um
how much does how much ocean has been
discovered
okay you hear that unexplored
yeah approximately five percent of the
ocean has been discovered
95 percent of the ocean i get it but
that's ridiculous okay now go look and
do the same thing with space 99.99
okay so you're basically saying you
believe in aliens versus the megalodon
no what i'm trying to say is
it's a lot easier to find out if we have
a megalodon because you're dealing with
whatever few miles versus it's
mathematically very can you pull it up
guy or no well
it's mathematically extremely
challenging to find out what is in space
that's infinity
how do you find that infinity you can't
so i'm going to say i'm going to lean
towards
only we've only explored roughly five
percent of the ocean yeah and then uh
we've explored an infinitely smaller
percentage of space
so i'm going to say there's more
likelihood to be aliens than i met with
them that's what i'm banking okay
what are the odds in vegas by the way
what are the odds in vegas is vegas
saying
i think you just did it right here
you've got this
do you know yeah okay so to me i think
uh you know
i think there are some ufos out there i
i don't know what's going to happen
i have some thoughts on this say it go
ahead okay so number one
why every time that they see
okay remember i think it's important to
identi to establish that a ufo is an
unidentified flying object just because
it's ufo doesn't mean it's an alien it's
just something that they don't
know what it is it's unidentified it
could be a drone it could be
a plane it could be a hot air balloon it
could be you know
a megalodon that's flying who knows
what's going on it's a ufo it's
unidentified
number two why every time that there's
quote unquote footage of this stuff it
looks like
you know your nanny cam that's in your
baby's bedroom that it you can probably
ten years ago and it's true exactly why
is it always something
you can so there was one pilot who said
yeah i went up there
every day i saw something every day this
was a big
60 minute so you went up there every day
you saw a ufo you didn't want to bring a
dope camera with you
you didn't want to let anybody know you
just kind of kept this your little
secret every day
no i don't know and then the last thing
how i know for a fact there's no aliens
there's no ufos because when you become
president united states they tell you
all the secrets
yeah give it up and you know if they
told trump there's some aliens that
mother sucker is telling people
oh i know there's alien he can't keep a
secret so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you